les révélations d'un a choisi huit et je
peux vous dire c'est incroyable
premières révélations ce livre revient
sur la rumeur qui avait fait mal à
johnny l'histoire d'une liaison secrète
voilà présumés entre laetitia et lenny
kravitz en mai 2008 le rockeur est à
saint barth pendant que laëtitia fait la
fête à plaire à paris la jeune femme est
en effet invité à l'anniversaire de
lenny kravitz et johnny n'arrivent pas à
joindre sa femme jo ni pleurs dans la
voiture répond moi dis moi où tu es à
saint barth dans ce cas pts 4 passes
ironie de la vie devant le cimetière de
lorient où il sera enterré dix ans plus
tard johnny cherche en vain depuis des
heures à joindre laëtitia le lendemain
laetitia lui assure qu'il ne s'est rien
passé
mais trop tard la presse people s'est
déjà emparée de la faire c'est une
révélation qu'il ya dans ce livre c'est
une révélation complètement folle et
voilà après sur cc ou et ça déjà ça
c'est un truc qu'on savait pas du tout
mine de rien il ça voilà on ne sait pas
si c'est vrai ou si c'est ton messahel
après ce tir n'a pas joué non laëtitia
mais je pas après c'est compliqué de
faire des formations mais je crois que
c'était à c'est un peu su de tous que
c'était un couple qui s'aimaient mais
qui avaient chacun de leur côté une
petite vie à part alors je l'aimais
comme ça se disait pour laetitia
j'ignorais pour lenny kravitz et on sait
aussi faim je crois sans trahir de
secrets que johnny hallyday de temps en
temps ça allait voir un petit peu
ailleurs après chacun vit son couple
juge pas mais vous êtes choqués pas les
révélations sur laëtitia
oui ou non oui ou mettez là non vous
restez là parce que et donc vous bouraba
reste vous êtes équipements aux cartes
vous vous dites non n'est pas choqué
mais alors non honnêtement dans le
milieu c'est des choses qui se disait
non non non effectivement c'est ce que
dit mathieu mais il faut penser moi je
le savais pas il n'avait pas pardonné
mais voilà alors je suis pas si c'est
vrai quand on voit la vraie mine de rien
donnez-moi syrie mais qu'est ce que ça
vous apporte par pardon ça c'est vous la
star est ce que c est ce que c'est elle
la star dans le couple il y avait une
star c'était johnny hallyday on n'est
plus obligé de connaître les histoires
de la femme de la star après semaine la
concierge de la femme de la semaine
après ça va être l'esthéticienne de la
star cadeaux
la femme de là il faut sourire pas tous
en même temps et franchement ce livre
honnêtement ce livre maintenant l'album
sort la dent danger pourquoi seconde
quoi un jeu plus pour apprendre quoi
qu'il arrive et des aventures à gauche à
droite est alors une petite répétition
pourquoi madame je vous dis des bêtises
on n'apprend rien ne dit rien alors
maintenant c'est normal mais l'album pas
sous le nom et moi moi je ne défends pas
alors je défends pas les noms mais mine
de rien benjamin on apprend les choses
on va encore parler grec l'autre
révélation lors de l'hommage national à
la madeleine ça ne se voyait pas
forcément l'écran mais de vives tensions
entre le clan laetitia et david laura
était présente donc laetitia et le clan
david et laura un conseiller de l'elysée
balance on a commencé à voir qu'il y
avait un problème entre ces personnes
quand on a reçu le placement dans
l'église on apprend que les deux
familles veulent que le couloir central
laissé par un conseiller de l'elysée a
dit ça sur laëtitia la vraie histoire
vous est ce que vous êtes choqués
j'aurais du tout choquée par la sortie
du livre au contraire ce sont celles
fournies l'anecdote qu'on connaissait
pas même si laval tu les connais c'est
moi j'ai connaissez pas un refuge à
pripiat un scoop des choses incroyables
dont on va parler juste après justement
choqué parce que malheureusement comme
le livre fait la part des choses entre
le côté lumineux et obscurité tissa les
gens quand ils tellement de salles et de
saleté qui ont été déversées sur et ne
veut retenir que ce côté encore nos
côtés obscurs des vénitiens
la preuve si on plaint de lenny kravitz
on parle pas des affidés était que
d'habitude parce que vous avez un livre
sur laëtitia est ce que oui ou non je
pense que très intéressant et on est
malin justement c'est que c'est un livre
sur laëtitia et pas sur johnny et du
coup on apprend la vie de laetitia
ce qu'elle vivait vous allez voir les
autres révélations que vous allez
annoncer son incroyable et au contraire
à croix pour la première fois en train
de changer d'avis je suis en train de me
rendre compte que cette fille malgré
tout avec eux aussi des atrocités des
choses très dures et vivre à côté de
johnny c'est pas facile parce qu'on va
découvrir des choses incroyables dans
l'ivresse et vous je suis en train de
choses je reconnais tu chanteras
aujourd'hui rendre compte que c'est pas
facile et et des siens alors qu'il n'y a
pas le compte je n'ai pas le contrôle ni
le quality cher et vous écrire ensemble
ça arrive complexe justement parce que
senior
ni à décharge ceni la sainte ni la [ __ ]
en fait et ce que nie la [ __ ] c'est ce
que dit le lier quel intérêt et j'ai
trouvé non mais moi je trouve que ça ça
ne me choque pas parce que je suis pour
la liberté d'expression s'arrêter là je
pense que la maison d'édition a fait
relire par une batterie de jury n'avait
pas coureurs pour évidemment pour ne pas
avoir de procès en revanche moi je
n'aime pas le voyeurisme
ah merde je trouve que ça nous ça ne
m'intéresse pas de savoir ce qui se
passe dans la chambre à coucher de
laëtitia mairie moi je pense même
apprécié là ça me choque pourquoi je
demande aux téléspectateurs
d'autres révélations bien sûr en privé
autre quoi révélations après la mort de
johnny l'hommage national à la madeleine
a eu lieu et on apprend encore de
nouvelles choses sur les people présents
un attaché de presse raconte des gens
m'appelaient en me disant and so est ce
qu'il ya une place pour moi je suis allé
en vacances chez lui il est venu en
vacances chez moi je les vues en slip
non mais c'est incroyable le vendredi
soir vers 18h30 le commando en voici 100
textos d'invitation autre info bernard
montiel a quant à lui été repêché in
extremis la veille au soir par david et
laura qu'il a connu tout petit c'est fou
parce que les gens ici à l'école je suis
allé chez les people qui ont refusé d'y
aller quand ils ont su qu'ils ne vais
pas dans l'église mais oui absolument
sakaba bien sinon gilles verdez moi je
suis extrêmement choqué par le livre
alors c'est un très bon livre je connais
un des deux co auteurs françois vignolle
tout est vrai tracé hyper béton super
travail
mais moi ce qui me choque c'est la
vision que ça donne de laëtitia pour moi
c'est un livre anti l'éthicien le doute
mais pas du tout entendu et ma vision
des choses
quand vous voyez pas 126 tu vois cette
[ __ ] je vais l'épouser
c'est johnny qui dit ça y parle de
laetitia comme ça pour moi ça ça mais
moi je vous le dis ça ne doit pas
figurer dans un de ces deux chambres
avait une vision de laetitia et de la
femme qui est trop violent
je vous dis que la vie m'a dérangé pour
ça mais là vous est pris le mauvais
exemple
ces prix mauvais exemple et dans wii la
somme a alors ya une autre révélation le
jour où johnny payer un appartement
alors en montant sur le prix à laetitia
fait partie des extraits fort du livre
johnny ne pouvait rien refuser à sa
fille mais laëtitia posait déjà l'époque
ses limites entre le père et sa fille ça
c'est plus embêtant pour l'éthicien
laetitia apprend le projet de son mari
mais qu'est ce que c'est que cette
connerie lui dit elle en substance
tu vas acheter un appartement une gamine
de 10
huit ans la jeune épouse fini par dire
oui là un studio mais il ne doit pas
coûter plus de 150000 euros
ça c'est une révélation on apprend aussi
plus loin dans le livre que johnny avait
bidonné l'acte de vente
en réalité l'appartement coûter beaucoup
plus cher ce que 150000 euros
et on apprend même que laura reçu 1,5
million d'euros de la part de jaunir et
oui oui oui monsieur l'abbé p 500 milles
benhalima l'anecdote est très bonne et
moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est l'avis des
cc johnnie lui mais moi je ne suis pas
intéressé par les histoires de petites
culottes benhalima excusez-moi beinheim
et là vous dites jamais arrivé des
bêtises qu'on va on craque pas des
histoires de poules titulariat ça prouve
sa prouve une chose ça prouve la
générosité de johnny et l'amour qu'il
avait pour sa fille il dit des bêtises
et dans chaque cas demain matin offrant
un livre sur votre femme et pas sur vous
le ciri le moment signalé depuis un an
et demi qu'on suit tous les jours
l'héritage ça nous intéressera le
bouquin et en appelle à des réponses ça
c'est pas une histoire que de petites
culottes juin je pense que les
téléspectateurs ont envie de voir
mine de rien la générosité johnny
l'amour qu'il avait pour ses enfants le
fait que voilà la mer en face des
chaudement des incendies c'est le rock n
roll freebox et leurs cadres c'est le
champ de bosses s'est rallumée
et fait retentir les câbles je t'aime on
a tous
alors voilà d'autres révélations johnny
[Musique]
johnny on va en parler
les mutants d'accord il avait comme
d'accord alors on apprend qu laura et
son père rencontrent secrètement se
rencontrent secrètement lors de
déjeuners sont l'évoqué à laëtitia
voit-il laurent en cachette d'une
laetitia jalouse qui n'accepteraient
passé d'autres enfants sont notre vie
est proche de laura en sont persuadés ça
c'est une vraie info on apprendra
médailles devant souffrir dionis est
aussi l'homme bah oui on n'y a pas un
truc que je savais donc bout d'un moment
c'est donc tout le monde a envie de
savoir aussi ce qui s'est réellement
passé la nuit ou au johnny nous a
quittés dans le livre on apprend
certains détails
il n'était pas encore révélé à peine
assis il a levé les yeux au ciel a
poussé un cri macabre et puis c'était
fini le docteur delgado tentent de le
réanimer pratiquer un massage cardiaque
en vain c'est à une heure du matin
qu'une décision est prise par rapport à
l'annoncé de la mort du rockeur à une
heure du matin
laetitia compose le numéro de la
première dame brigitte ne dort pas avec
votre permission je passerai demain lui
répond l'épousé du président et c'est
vrai que ça voilà vous avez la manière
dont vous êtes en train de lire illustre
la qualité du livre c'est à dire que
c'est prenant comme un roman oui mais
tout est vrai c'est super bien écrit 2 à
0 5 me c'est la thèse de laëtitia mais
c'est un bouquin où il ya plein d'infos
vous pouvez pas dire que rien donné
jeudi par bien dedans c'est que ce qu'il
ya dedans ça va moi ne sers pas comme
excuse moi je galérais chaque passage
est serré et passionnant valérie à m
moi j'entends dire sans foi de moi j'ai
une star c'est johnny j'ai eu la chance
en plus de croiser etc
je suis désolé on veut intéresser johnny
sait mais moi moi ça me plaît là ce que
j'apprends que ça tourne je vois qu'il
voit sa fille en cachette et cham
attendri et ça remet les choses à leur
place ce à tort d'ailleurs le cou à la
rumeur qui avait dit que les tissages
des rues et pour rappel afp quand son
mari taymans lieu d'appeler mes enfants
de jean alors qu'on apprend c'est pas
elle qui a pris la fpc faire appeler
directement au caire s'arrête à mes
pinceaux et alors et pardon mais il
fallait la troisième l'info vous allez
dire maintenant quand je les lui mais
j'étais si je tombé de l'armoire dont je
suis tombé de l'armoire comme le renomme
peut faire ça alors justement je vais
vous révéler une des anecdotes du livre
qui est folle c'est une des anecdotes
les plus folles sur le couple qui
révélait dans ce livre on apprend que
lors d'un dîner à s'arroser et après un
violent accrochage entre andré boudou le
père de laeticia et johnny laeticia a
fini par dessus bord
laetitia d'essence enfermé dans sa
cabine hésité sur le bateau tandis que
le rockeur sens qu'ils dérobent banane
sur le pont alors que johnny ans qui un
énième cocktail laetitia prend son
courage à deux mains et vient se planter
devant lui écoute mamour franchement
avec mon père tu as été un peu laëtitia
n'a pas le temps de finir sa phrase que
johnny a déjà soulevé et jeté à l'eau
alors ça moi je dis que c'est apprendre
à eau conditionnée moi je sais pas si
c'est vrai moi la voix je suis fan
absolu des fans absolus de grigny c2c
deux mousses ça par exemple j'avais pas
envie de le savoir alors le taulier
pointe laetitia du doigt et lance à son
ami tu vois cette [ __ ]
je vais l'épouser ça c'était après
c'était pas le premier extrait de colère
de johnny envers laëtitia il dit je vais
l'épouser elle est gentil tu sais je
n'aime pas être seul elle est jeune ça
pas c'est bon pour moi et johnny avait
aussi des excès de colère il ya ça andré
j ch
johnny avait aussi des excès de colère
face à andré boudou le père de laeticia
comme jour où ce dernier avait séquestré
un soi-disant amant de laetitia dans une
cave
à peine arrivé andré boudou s'est rué
sur lui jonnhy ce qu'il appelle jauni je
vais donner une correction je les punir
garde et là on a vu sortir un pauvre mec
à gars qui n'avait rien mangé ni bu
depuis trois jours il a hurlé sur boudou
mais tu es malade c'était une
plaisanterie complètement fou alors ça
c'est une banale mais ce qu'on apprend
ça veut dire c'est qu'on aime ou pas
johnny hallyday il buvait voilà on va
dire les choses trop voilà souvent déjà
à mettre au conditionnel
il avait cette anecdote c'est pas avec
ebay qui l'avait il avait dit dans le
monde il avait donné des interviews mais
ne sais pas si l'interview est vrai je
sais pas je sais qu'après ce qui est dit
c'est que 2,2 mousse pas de deux
personnages du bord l'on remonte et
lætitia l'ont ramené dans sa chambre
évidemment que si c'est vrai c'est
horrible ce qu'avec eux aussi cette
fille est dès maintenant donc c'est
trets et si c'est vrai heureusement
qu'on le dit on dit ah c'est que les
flags ils sont un peu violente et
malheureusement elle n'ose pas parler
honte et leur souffrance est bien là au
lieu dit eh beh même si c'est une star
c'est bien mais alors ya deux autres
révélations que voulait dont on voulait
parler je n'ai ni des voiliers sa vie et
sa carrière dirigé d'une main de maître
par sa femme elle s'occupait de son
image de ses interviews mais ça tout le
monde le savait le livre révèle aussi
qu'elle s'occupait de son physique
on apprend que laëtitia des forces et
johnny à faire de la chirurgie
esthétique lui qui n'aimait pas trop
toucher à son physique il a malgré tout
suivi les conseils de sa femme dans
l'entourage du rockeur nombreux sont
ceux qui jure mordicus avoir lu et
entendu laetitia lui susurrer mamour tu
devrais te faire repulper la bouche
le résultat s'avère catastrophique a au
final johnny avait les lèvres gonflées
et peiné à chanter on a retrouvé les
images de ce concert à las vegas qui a
été un fiasco à l'époque il avait une
bouche voilà bouche de canard révèle le
livre et c'était à cause de cette
chirurgie esthétique regarder
[Musique]
non non moi qui tu es
alors enfin l'extrait le plus fort du
livre on vous l'a gardé c'est vraiment
le extrait plus fort on l'apprend mais
on apprend les nombreux mais aux
mensonges de la part de laetitia elle
mentait sur son passé pour plaire à
johnny c'est mamie rock donc sa
grand-mère qui balancent laetitia diageo
dit que son père l'avait battu avec une
cravache ce n'est pas vrai comme johnny
avait eu une jeunesse malheureuse elle
voulait montrer qu elle aussi avait été
malheureuse andré boudou le père de
laeticia s'est d'ailleurs insurgé après
les propos de sa fille même avec une
fleur ma fille je ne les jamais battu je
n'ai jamais battu personne ce sont des
inventions
laëtitia avait continué à mentir aussi à
propos de son enfance et son adolescence
puis de sa carrière de mannequin elle
n'a pas été une adolescente qui tend à
13 ans la france pour miami afin de
soigner un père si dévastée par un
chagrin d'amour qu'il en avait perdu
envie de lire elle ne devient pas ce
mannequin que s'arrachent et les
photographes laëtitia a juste été
modelée par johnny donc voilà on apprend
donc deux balles à de nombreux mensonges
est ce que ce livre vous a choqué ou pas
vous nous dites enfin des extraits dont
on vous parle
oui vous vous lire âge et moi j'étais
plus choqué parce qu'on peut révéler sur
johnny parce que ça fait même pas un an
qu'il est mort et je trouve ça très
déplacées notamment même si oui il
faudra le dire un jour mais je ne pense
en ce n'était pas le moment
en revanche on aussi le livre très très
bien fait on oscille sans arrêt entre
pour letizia une femme aimante qui
vraiment cédé vous et moi ya des moments
où c'est je trouve des passages très
très émouvant notamment elle a menti
pour le séduire par ce qu'elle était
amoureuse
sinon moi je trouve que ce n'est pas un
livre à charge contre laeticia ce tour
alors à non moi j'ai trouvé que c'est
une femme qui a subi beaucoup de choses
c'est une femme amoureuse
oui la scène de la mort est vraiment
très très émouvante donc lui rajouter
quelque chose oui on parle de vous dans
le livre vous aviez sabawi à la page 2
on parle de vous ah oui je connard
d'hanouna l'émission tous ramer direct
en novembre 2013
where ce que arthur évoque à un moment
les moments difficiles et moments de
pression qu'il a eu et il parle d'un
concert de johnny et lors de ce concert
il a évoqué sa relation avec estelle le
problème c'est qu'elle était encore
mariée à david à ce moment là c'est vrai
c'est un moment très improbable de l'aca
examen je crois qu'on la voit regardons
à la baisse et le concert de johnny un
ouais quand j'ai présenté johnny au
stade de france
ou par des principes et où c'était une
époque en plus j'ai chuté avec la femme
de son fils d'audrey un peu compliqué
comme ambiance
mais s'il sait pas s'il fait tout cela
veut dire est que mireille dumas alors
il se confie c'est chaud ça c'est chaud
c'est vrai ouais c'est incroyable et ça
c'est dans le livre j'ai bien les 1 2
70e absolument et ça en fait il ya
tellement d'anecdotes
ils ont eu tellement d'interlocuteurs
que tout devient crédible et tous met en
place marco tout et tout est vrai dans
les chemins des deux côtés je le connais
très bien vignolles alors j'ai bossé
avec lui au parisien
tout est verrouillé loriot qui est très
seul oui absolument mais bien sûr mais
moi je connais l'autre il aurait rien
laissé passé qu'ils ne soient faux là
dessus au point de faire confiance oui
sincèrement le livre est tout à fait
conforme à ce qu'on a lui-même est
entendu par johnny donc moi je trouve
que le livre est une sorte de sommes
jouées à dans la vie de raymond qui
était fan de johnny aussi des drapeaux
est chauffeur livreur le matin vous êtes
doté pmp le soir on vous kiffe vous en
tant que téléspectateur qu'est ce que
vous dites est ce que vous êtes choqués
par ce livre moi je suis très choqué par
ce livre et je rejoins valérie parce que
je pense qu'ils ont ratissé très large
ils ont mis du bien comme il nous
explique comment johnny et les parties
moi ça m'a touché de savoir comment ils
étaient partis en revanche de savoir
qu'il a jetté laetitia au dessus d'un
bateau elle était sur un bateau à l'oeil
27 ans je pense pas qu'elle était
malheureuse sur les 27 ans qu'elle a
vécu je pense pas qu'il lui a apporté
que du malheur prennent vraiment ce
qu'elle a vu que j'attends j'ai essayé
de m'expliquer je ne dis pas que c'est
une raison
je dis juste que le livre quand on
m'explique kidal qui dit tu vois cette
[ __ ] je me marie avec à quoi ça sert
à quoi ça m'apporte ça m'apporterait
rien du tout savoir ça laissez les en
paix laissez-les venez c'est l'infini
ils ont vécu une vie de couple s'était
marié 27 ans et des tumultes cdc des
épisodes mois ce qui m'embête c'est que
le livre il est payant les gens ils vont
l'acheter pour un peu ça va pas changer
leur vie
il est payant mais non alors par se
faire du fric parce qu'ils ont ratissé
large
jean michel jean michel bezat goût des
livres gratuits d'aucune et des
biographies sur toi tu verras tu seras
pas que ça n'a rien à voir
rapport je suis pas noir je rêve de
tourner en vigueur pour les chaussées de
ces diktats de la transparence parce
qu'à l'en dans deux ans il ya quoi y'a
le professeur khayat qui était le
cancérologue de johnny qui va écrire un
livre sur comment johnny était dans ses
dernières années après dans cinq ans il
y aura le rif calissons médicale
non pas du tout il focalise qui dira
comment ça s'est passé va bien tu es
alors mais tu vas tu passais pas le
produit sur johnny pardon au chaud
depuis le jour où il est mort le jour où
il a été enterré on suit toutes les
étapes de leur vie de haine et machin
pour une fois qu'on a un bouquin enfin
qui rétablit la vérité c'est
effectivement tout est vrai on a pour du
johnny pour de laëtitia on a la vérité
au contraire de quoi vous plaignez que
sa tête a apprécié le nouveau disque de
diamant va clôturer ce qu'il a l'air
très énervé pas bien j'avais mes profs
vous êtes énervé parce que vous m'avez
tous gonflés binger droit de pas être
d'accord will et moi pour n'est pas
d'accord il avait renoncé données c'est
trop tôt c'est pas maintenant à la
loyale l'album qui sort yann bouffin sur
wii les choses auraient bien sûr mais
moi je veux pas savoir ça maintenant ça
me dérange ça me fait de la peine pour
lui je foutez lui la paix non non non
non je fais mes toiles de jute feu très
vite et pardon benjamin m'excuse mode
c'était le premier grand écran bien sûr
toute ta famille et sa vie
[Rires]
la balle est maintenant dans sa bouche
mais chez les ch et on va l'envoyer sur
son cas de johnny ont fait ça me blesse
pour tout pour tout le monde pour ses
enfants
c'est pas bien pas maintenant c'est
dégueulasse très bien écrit celui qui
n'est pas là comme ça qui va dévoiler
mes chances bien c'est votre émission
[ __ ] bâtisse à les gars je les fais
depuis tout à l'heure et aux mamies
almatois on est on est en train de gérer
un enfant difficile
[Rires]
serait on en train de virer les scieries
le grand frère viendra demain s'occuper
du benjamin castaldi
mais benjamin c'est pour ça que je laime
il est tellement comme ça et dans deux
minutes il va jouer avec mon ping pong
et ça je pourrais de la peine